[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof hi Walter hi Martin how
are you doing I'm good well no you can't
say you're good because the Bible says
there's no one good no not one that's
why I said
well okay so uh yes um we are in a
situation at this time of Earth's
history where we are bound to repeat
what has gone before
yes but we should not do that but we
often improve on what went before so
let's ask the Holy Spirit to help
because we have to do some important
discussion yeah yes this is a a
balancing act
yes y our only father we are so thankful
that we have you in our life because
without you we wouldn't understand or be
able to discern anything so we ask now
with the help of the holy spirit that we
can discern and put this together so
that your people can be warned in jesus'
name amen
amen Martin shall we put a disclaimer
right in the beginning
maybe that's a good idea and make it
quite clear that this is not an
attack it is an
observation yes now it's called worse
than
they and we'll see where that comes from
it is of course a quote worse than they
Isaiah 4:6 says my people are destroyed
for lack of knowledge
because thou Hast rejected knowledge I
will also reject thee and thou shalt be
no priest to me seeing that thou has
forgotten the law of thy God I will also
forget thy
children that's quite
a profound statement isn't
it well I think it's a warning that God
is giving yes so it's a profound
statement and if you don't adhere to it
there's even a warning to tell you what
will happen all right this was given to
Israel of
old does it apply to Modern Israel no
definitely all right so it applies so
our people are destroyed for lack of
knowledge now what prompted this
discussion in the first
place well let's give a little bit of a
historic
background there have been many
occasions
when there have been observations that
all is not necessarily well mhm within
our ranks within the
church and there are some people that
believe that you must uh you know expose
it and I believe that too because the
Bible clearly says that uh you are
responsible also for your brother you
are your brother's
keeper that doesn't make you your
brother's policeman and it doesn't give
you the right to become your brother's
policeman and it also doesn't give you
the right to go and sit on a judgment
chair and decry people as lost MH they
could be on a journey right yes because
there's that is only God's prerogative
that's God's prerogative he sits on the
Judgment chair all judgment has been
given to Christ so we must get down from
the Judgment chair and we' received a
lot of criticism because some people
believe that
bashing the church is the way to reveal
all of these things and to name names
and do all of those things and we've
always said no that's not the way we
intend to do that but if people had
listened carefully to what we say we
address all the the things that are
disturbing of course but we don't
mention the names now people want us to
mention men the names and we don't want
to mention the names but there's a good
reason why we don't want to because if
you mention a name then all attention is
drawn unto the person in send of onto
the sin and there are people that have
severed their ties with the church and
say this church has become apostate
because this one is doing that and that
one is doing the other and are we
sitting with our heads in the sand and
say nothing are we cowards etc etc
uh I believe the church is the apple of
the Lord's eye
mhm and uh if he loves
her then we should love her too Y and if
she is not so
lovable then we should ask ourselves why
would God give his life for a not so
lovable
Church yeah is that right that's a very
good question okay so that's another
point and uh
do we address these things well if
people would look at our history now
you're not in this as long as I am
you're trying to catch
up but uh I've had numerous altercations
with uh in situations which which were
devastating but I'm still here yeah yeah
and I don't intend to to leave either
and we always say put glue on your
posterior and and stay then people say
how can you expect me to stay I said
don't don't necessarily have to stay in
that particular situation or that
denomination that has gone totally
Haywire but stay within the body that's
the point
right and uh then people complain that
we are not uh direct enough well I have
written public letters if there have
been public incidences and people could
go check them out on the web because
they're
available and I've written to
conferences even to
leadership uh sometimes because uh
people wanted me to explain
myself and one of them is even published
one of those letters is published in my
wife's book yeah so people can read it
for themselves and see whether these
things have been addressed and I think
they have but uh let's let's have a look
how Jesus went about it he was uh very
harsh in his condemnation of the
Pharisees but he didn't mention them by
name no and he didn't expose the
individuals he could have said when he
was there with the lady that was caught
in adultery and he wrote In The Sands
the sins of the others interesting that
he wrote it in sand so you just do that
and it's gone again right yeah and he
let them see it he didn't broadcast it
he was he was so diplomatic so subtle
and if he really had something that was
burdening him he put it in a parable
that's it so he didn't go to the
individual and point him out yes and I
wonder whether people notice our
Parables we have many of them how many
times do we say even within our own
ranks exactly what else does that mean
what does that mean that means if people
don't know that anyone that qualifies
that to the thing that we've just
mentioned yes it's not only one person
because say for instance we take on one
person yes and they get rid of that one
person have you gotten rid of the
problem no the problem remains because
there are 10 15 20 a thousand in the
shadows who will take the place you must
address the issue yes and hopefully the
individual will recognize the issue and
might change you don't know as I often
say I he an Aaron yeah who made a golden
cough and then lied about it oh this
cough jumped out of the
fire was he condemned no no because you
don't know so be very careful before you
judge so we want to address some of
these things because people say we are
not mentioning them we've mentioned them
a thousand times if they can't see it
then they are not listening yes but
let's address it let's say why in spite
of it this church this is the Lord's
Church yeah and don't you dare call it
Babylon yeah and don't you dare call
people out of it no let's be quite plain
about that yes all right so my people
are destroyed for lack of
knowledge I was just recently part of a
a radio
interview as to why people leave the
church and why the young people in
particular are leaving the
church and that makes you think as to
why are they leaving the church what is
the matter why are they leaving the
church and then this text comes to mind
my people are destroyed for lack of
knowledge but maybe you can just expound
a little bit but what knowledge is
referring to you yes what do we need to
know what is it that is so
important and you know why are we as a
denomination in such a prominent
position in the world and so
different and why is it so uncomfortable
for many to be so different M why is it
so NE necessary to feel accepted by the
world when the criteria that God applies
is s are such that he says separate
yourself from the world so if you love
the world you're an enemy of God says
the Bible exactly it's a big problem
right it's a big problem so that must
tell you something peer pressure must be
one of the reasons for sure but lack of
knowledge I then spoke to some young
people and you know just asking some
basic basic things and I I came to the
horrifying
conclusion that they they don't know why
we are a Remnant yeah they don't know
what happened in 1844 oh there was a
disappointment that's not uh so you guys
got it wrong right that's what the world
says they don't understand the prophetic
unfolding they don't understand the 70
weeks they don't know where we are in
the stream of time they don't understand
why the church is in the state or why
it's not more like the world for sure I
mean you can actually change the wording
from the great disappointment to the
great Enlightenment to know that God is
walk Jesus has walked from the holy to
the most holy and are in the Judgment
seat yes the time of his judgment has
come what does that mean and all of
these things and I just thought to
myself
with all these accusations flying around
and the young people leaving the church
and to me the worst is those that should
know better leaving the church and
barking on the outside come out of her
because she's become Babylon now do we
deny that there are wrongs in the church
on the contrary we every citation we
point to that you can acknowledge the
problems there is the problem but that's
not the that's not the the situation the
situation is this church what does it
stand
for and if there are individuals in the
church that do not adhere to what the
church stands for that's not the church
that is apostate that's the individual
or the group even if it is a massive
group yes that's problematic right so
let's jump into this and I think it
could be a lengthy discussion and if uh
Jesus used
Parables then we can use some Parables
as well right for
sure in Jesus's
Parables the people that were addressed
knew that he was addressing them and and
they were red-faced or they were
exceeding ly
angry or they repented that's you have
those choices you have those choices
well worse than they who's the
they well this refers to Israel of
old that uh The Remnant Church let's
call it by its name the Seventh Day
Adventist Church is worse than they yeah
now that's not just dragging out of a
hat it's not an
accusation it is a prophetic statement
the
worse all right doesn't make them any
less the apple of the Lord's eye no all
right so let's go to ancient
Israel and we we're getting to the time
when Moses was about to depart his time
had come he had stood with his people
he'd seen all the turmoils all the
apostasies he had uh offered
himself as a ransom
blot me from the book of life but let
them live he he'd been in this
situation and this should be a lesson
for us he didn't
leave I mean if there was anybody that
had good reason to leave it was him it
was him right now people will say well
eventually you know Jesus came and they
left the church no they never left the
church they were the church the others
the multitude that didn't accept kept
the Messiah according to the prophecies
they were shaken out because they didn't
go along with the Messiah so let's just
go to Deuteronomy to this point where
Moses was actually instructed to write a
song now if you read that song you would
say that's no
song but it was a song because it had
all the elements of the Rhythm and the
rhyme and the parallelisms and all of
these things
so that's actually recorded in
Deuteronomy chapter 32 but let's just
take a few verses out of chapter
31 and Moses called unto Joshua this is
Deuteronomy
31:7 and said unto him in the sight of
all Israel be strong and of good courage
for thou must go with this people into
the land which the Lord has sworn unto
their fathers to give them and the Thou
shalt cause them to inherit them you
know now you can just see Moses standing
there he'd been through all the troubles
all the apostasies he'd witnessed
everything and he looked at this crowd
and they really weren't much better yeah
then the generation that was standing in
front of him yes they really weren't
much better and he said you must go with
this people there you go with this
people I can just see him going oh my
with this people you have to go you
imagine it I can really I can see him
and the Lord he is it that does go
before thee he will be with thee he will
not fail thee neither forsake the fear
not neither be dismayed where's the
emphasis on who is going to be the
deliverer and the perfect one on God
it's on Jesus on God now there are
people that want to turn this round and
and say the church has to be Immaculate
before it can go in but uh let's just
review some of these issues I know we're
going to get Flack no matter what we say
from both sides but who cares right
let's let's most of the time we've
already stated that uh we're quoting
Bible and spirit of Prophecy so your
Flack is not actually directed towards
us okay all right I feel much better now
thank you for that Mar
all right then he says and the Lord said
unto Moses behold Thou shalt sleep with
thy fathers and this people mhm this
this people that people will rise up and
go a
whoring okay were they great no they
weren't great this people will go a
whing after the gods of the strangers of
the land whether they go to be amongst
them and will forsake me and break my
Covenant which I made with
them so Martin if we're worse than them
mhm does this apply to us for sure all
right so can we expect that this people
will go a whing
yes this people as well okay Deuteronomy
31:17 then my anger shall be kindled
against them that day and I will forsake
them and I will hide my face from them
and they shall be devoured and many
evils and troubles shall befall them so
that they will say in that day are not
these evils come upon us because our God
is Not amongst us verse 19 says now
therefore write ye this song for you and
teach it to the children of Israel put
it in their mouth that this song may be
a witness for me against the children of
Israel now when the Lord forsook them
did he really forsake them no he just
let them do you know be do what you want
and see what consequences and get into
big trouble right but he always still
preserved them in their trouble and then
took them out again he's like a father
it's exactly what a father does to a
child okay go and try it and you'll come
I know you're right okay I I'll keep a
watchful eye that you don't get
destroyed in the process but uh this is
the way it's going to be all right so
that's the backdrop that's what the
children were
like verse 22 says Moses therefore wrote
this song the same day and taught it to
the children of Israel so he went and he
sat down and he wrote a song on
inspiration and he gave Joshua the son
of nun charge and said be strong and of
good courage for Thou shalt bring the
children of Israel into the land which I
swear unto thee and I will be with thee
isn't that a beautiful promise and it
came to pass when Moses had made an end
of writing the words of this law in a
book until they were finished that Moses
commanded the Levites that he should put
it in the side of the Ark and the whole
of the ceremonial law and all of this
thing this is not the song yet no but
this is the backdrop so here's
everything that you need to survive
everything has been written for you and
you're going to go a
whing we already know
it verse 27 and I Know Thy rebellion and
thy stiff neck behold while I am yet
alive with you this day you have been
rebellious against the Lord and how much
more after my death so the Lord in his
wisdom gave them a prophet Moses he
wrote everything he wrote
copiously and he told them their past
and he told them what's wrong with them
and how they should live and he told
them their future yeah and he said Put
it beside the ark and right next to the
law and please read it and remember
remember remember remember
remember and I know that the moment I
die you're going to be a whing because
you did whing while I was still with
you jump to the
Future did God in his wisdom give the
end time Church writings to lead them on
the way yes copious
writings even more than what Moses left
in the Canon look at our
backdrop switch to the backdrop
screen and there you see a pen writing
and writing and writing testimonies to
the church volume 1 volume two volume 3
volume 4 volume 9
eventually ah messages to young people
counsels on diets and food uh conflict
of the age is serious copious copious
writing they rebellious while the
writings were going on yes they very
much
so and according to this six how much
more after the death of that Prophet
will it go from bad to good or from bad
to worse much
worse okay all right that's very
encouraging Martin
uh it's a fact that's the point fact
it's a it's stated there's no denying
there's no denying all right then he
continues from verse 28
onwards gather unto me all the Elders of
your tribes and all your officers that I
may speak these words in their ears and
call Heaven and Earth to record against
them after all of those meetings 1888
and
1889 and all of the issues that came up
were
there occasions when all the elders were
together and there was a serious talk
about what was wrong yes did it happen
many times is it a parallel yes for
sure
okay it's going to stand there as a
record against
them are there copious writings backdrop
mhm as a record against God's people yes
okay we've got it in both in the Bible
and the copia writings for I know that
after my death as is Moses speaking you
will utterly corrupt yourselves and turn
aside from the way which I have
commanded you and evil will befall you
in the latter days is this a reference
to the Future
yes okay way in the future what is this
a parallel yeah okay now if you know
that this parabel is going to happen are
you going to stand on the outside and
bar no if you do you haven't put the
parabel into context for yourself you
haven't no you haven't because you will
do evil in the sight of the Lord to
provoke him to anger through the work of
your hands can we expect it
yes okay
ftic all right Martin so here we have
the same picture as we have on our
backdrop except that the hand has become
a lot
older was Moses a lot older yes he was
40 years older than when he started off
with them coming out of Egypt okay so
here we have a hand that is at least 60
years older but at this stage probably
round about that then when it started to
write right
mhm and it was a constant testimony a
constant testimony and some accepted it
yes but many did not right yeah which is
a very very sad State of Affairs so
let's have a look how Moses wrote
song this is
Moses which song which starts in chapter
32 verse 30 in chapter 31 says and Moses
spoke in the ears of all the
congregation of Israel the words of the
song until they were
ended give ear oh ye heavens and I will
speak and hear o Earth the words of my
mouth now this is so poetic this is a
merism mhm okay you have to explain a
merism is where you put
two extreme
opposites and that then entails the two
opposites and everything in between okay
so you have give ear o you Heavens right
up there and I will speak and hear Earth
yes down here it tells everything in
between so from what happened in heaven
the Rebellion that happened in heaven to
the Rebellion that's going to happen
down here and everything in between is
basically encased in this song okay it's
beautiful beautiful starts off with a
with a
poetic Onslaught if I can say it that
way now what is he going to say to us
he's going to say my
Doctrine shall drop as the rain my
speech shall distill as the Jew what do
we have there that's a Hebrew
parallelism see so this is very poetic
for sure now the the Hebrew poetry was
not necessarily the same as ours you
know we have the Rhythm and the rhyme
there's Rhythm and there's rhyme and
there's all of these things in there as
well but then they have the merms and
they have the typologies and they have
the KMS and they have the parallelisms
and it's really magnificent
yeah it is divine and it is to emphasize
certain portions yes all right so what
is the doctrine obviously the speech
yeah so what God had said didn't God
speak through Moses so God spoke through
Moses and Moses wrote it down and
whatever is written down that's Doctrine
that's it can you ignore Doctrine no but
the Pope says You
must I don't care you don't care I don't
care either all right so my Doctrine
shall drop as the rain my speech shall
distill as the
due as the small rain upon the tender
herb and as the showers upon the grass
because I will publish the name of the
Lord ascribe ye greatness unto God
what's the song about about God the song
is about God that's it all right so in
case you thought Martin that you were
going to move the Earth no you're not
going to do it you're probably going to
end up in
but uh God will move the Earth exactly
he is the
rock his work is perfect for all his
ways are judgment the god of Truth and
without iniquity just and right he is
bottom line and it's also referring to
which person of the godhead it's
speaking all right now this poem is not
only merism it's not only KMS it's not
only Hebrew parallelism it's also
contrast yeah so that was God was like
the rock they' have corrupted themselves
their spot is not the spot of his
children they are perverse and crooked
generation that's the oh the contrast
doesn't look so good right not at all
but now what about all these people that
think that they have to be the goody
goody two shoes aren't they missing the
boat here no exactly the onlyone who's
going to be perfect is God indeed can I
expect perfection in God's people no
should we strive for sure that's what I
there's a difference right yeah strive
for it and become as perfect in your
sphere as he is in your sphere but if
you think that you've become the bee's
knees then watch it yeah then you're
already there all right do ye thus Reit
the Lord O foolish people and
unwise Martin the prognosis is not
good and not is not he thy father that
has bought thee has he not made thee and
established thee can you see the the
fourth Commandment there no for sure and
bought thee with what and then the
followed by the word
remember it's beautiful isn't it the
days of old consider the years of many
generations ask thy father and he will
show thee thy elders and they will tell
thee when the most high divided to the
Nations their inheritance when he
separated the sons of Adam he set the
bounds of the people according to number
of the children of Israel for the Lord's
portion is his people Jacob is the lot
of his
inheritance in spite of what they are
like a foolish people and unwise what
are they the apple of his eye they are
in his inheritance that's what he has
yeah and he is grateful to have it
exactly he knows that all these nonsense
God loves them yes
okay he found him in a desert land and
in the waste howling Wilderness he led
him about he instructed him he kept him
as the apple of his eye does God care
about his people
oh yes definitely but what are they
foolish and unwise yeah they go a horing
exactly but he still loves them blind
and naked
as an eagle stirreth up a nest fluth
over a young spreadeth abroad her wings
taketh them beareth them in his wings so
the Lord alone did lead him and there
was no strange god with him is that
poetry yes that's a song right yeah and
it puts God up where he belongs and us
where we belong yes let's just make
quite sure that we understand the
distinction he made him ride on the high
places of the earth that he might eat
the increase of his field and he made
him suck honey out of the Rock and oil
out of the flinty Rock and butter and
kind and milk of sheep and fat of lambs
and Rams is that a license to eat
whatever you want or is that poetry
poetry it's like uh land overflowing
with milk and honey isct literal or is
it talking of prosperity it's talking
about Prosperity where do you ever read
that they went to a rock and sucked
honey out of it it didn't happen right
so people must must must realize that
we're dealing with
poetry but
jesuan now what is jeson jeson is a term
of endearment for
Israel it's like like calling your wife
wife lovey yeah all right hello lovey
and sometimes she's not so lovey but you
call her lovey anyway it's a pet name
it's a pet name but Jeron waxed fat and
and
kicked Thou Art wax and fat Thou Art
grown thick Thou Art covered with
fatness then he forsook God which made
him and lightly esteem the rock of his
salvation does that sound like uh loud
here yeah they took what the God what
God gave that was good for them and
they've turn turned it around into a
nightmare for themselves okay so you
have become rich and increased in goods
and you are need of nothing is there any
difference here no nothing it's just a
different terminology yeah it's very
poetic I actually like it and it's still
referring to the remnant church it's
still referring to it here it was Israel
and ludia it's the end time all right so
he provoke them to jealousy now M let's
say God tells
you I want you to read these verses and
observe and see there's the Antichrist
and you know who the Antichrist is
because he tells you exactly who it is
in Daniel chapter 7 he uses a prophet to
tell
you and then you say but he's my brother
I'm going to S with him and bow down
before his altars would that provoke the
Lord to jealousy yes he tells you it's
the Antichrist and you go whoring with
him that it doesn't it doesn't work
right no okay it could never happen
happen
right oh no all right let's leave it at
that for the moment all right so they
provoked him to jealousy with strange
god with Abominations provoke the him to
anger God warns you about something and
you say it's not so it's 19th century
literature I'm going to ignore it that
would provoke him and then you sacrifice
unto
Devils now if you take part in a in a
ritual like the mass for example
where you know that there are dead bones
in that Al
altar because it is a it is a sacrifice
to the dead y isn't that sacrificing to
Devils oh for sure whenever you do
something that you know is against what
God wants for the sake of compromise and
mingling with the opposite side all
right did they what did they then become
not God's people because they did this
no they still stayed his people all
right I'm not saying they were saved all
of them no no no did some of them repent
yes when that golden cough jumped
out of the fire and there it was did
some of those people repent yes didn't
Aaron repent yes he did so if he
repented then didn't some of the others
yeah were there some that didn't take
part in that Festival yes the
Levites and that's why they were chosen
to become the priests later on right
okay it's wasn't Aaron a levite yes so
did all the Levites uh stand firm no
okay all right all right so to Gods whom
they knew not to New Gods that came
newly up whom your fathers feared not of
the rock that begat thee Thou Art
unmindful and have forgotten God that
formed thee
and here we have the word forgotten
again and there's a word remember in the
fourth Commandment right so that is it
possible that a Sabbath keeper can
forget God
yes when it becomes legalistic to you
all right and you're doing it on a Works
basis instead of a relationship basis
okay and and if you don't know why
you're doing that yeah and when the Lord
saw it he abhold them because of the
provoking of his sons and of his
daughters and he he said I will hide my
face from them I will see what their end
shall be for they are very fraed
generation children in whom is no
faith all right so they were they were
messing with the minds of his children
through their
apostasy and the Lord said I will hide
my face from them they are fraed they
are arrogant
yeah forgetting that God was their
creator
yes they have moved moved me to jealousy
with that which is not God now we must
remember that God's jealousy is not like
our
jealousy they have provoked me to anger
with their vanities and I will move them
to jealousy with those who are not a
people I will provoke them to anger with
a foolish
Nation he's throwing a hint that he's
going to call the Gentiles and give them
what they are refusing to take and long
before he actually did it long before he
did it for a fire is kindled in mine
anger and shall burn unto the lowest
hell and shall consume the Earth with
their increase and set on fire the
foundations of the mountains so he's
actually talking about what's going to
happen now M when he called the N the
the
Gentiles did he take it away from Israel
and give it to the Gentiles or did he
make the Gentiles part of his Covenant
he made them part of the Covenant
although the wording that is put there
says that I will take it away and give
it to them yes but he actually brought
them men because before that he says in
many places that he will call the
Gentiles and all that Worship in his
Temple and that keep the Sabbath they
will be his
children I will Heap Mischief upon them
I will spend mine arrows upon them they
shall be burnt with hunger devoured with
burning heat bitter destruction and he
tells them everything that will happen
to them the Poison Serpents of the Dust
the sword without the terror within
shall destroy both the young man and the
Virgin the suckling also with the man of
gray hairs and I would scatter them into
Corners I would make the remembrance of
them to cease from amongst men were it
not that I feared the wroth of the enemy
lest the adversity should be behave
themselves strangely unless they should
say our hand is high and the Lord has
not done all this for there are a nation
void of counsel neither is there any
understanding in
them it's just a status quo that's what
they
are oh that they were wise that they
understood this that they would consider
their latter end how should one chase a
th and two put 10,000 to flight except
their Rock had sold them and the Lord
had shut them up it's beautiful H it's
still part of this beautiful song it
that's why people say no it's going to
can't be a song but this is again just
putting it in contrast the whole time
what now Moses is is presenting this to
the people do you think they enjoyed
it I think it spoke to the heart when
this sermon was given I think some of
them would say to him just get off that
Pulpit Lord never gave you this this is
your doing yeah yeah yeah for their rock
is not as our Rock even our enemies
themselves being judges for their Vine
is of the vine of
Sodom is that possible
Martin unfortunately
yes and of the fields of gamor their
grapes are grapes of gold their clusters
are bitter the win is the poison of
dragons and the cruel Venom of ass is
not this laid up in stored with me
sealed up amongst my treasures to me
belongeth Vengeance and recompense their
foot shall slide in due time for the day
of their Calamity is at hand and the
things that shall come upon them make
haste is there a warning in this mod
yeah that's a very strong sentiment from
God there why because the Lord shall
judge his people and repent himself of
his servants when he seeth that their
power is gone and there's none shut up
or left and he shall say where are their
gods their Rock in whom they trusted
which did eat the fat of their
sacrifices and drank the wine of their
drink offerings let them rise up and
help you and be your
protection do you think the Antichrist
will help God's people in the end no he
will what about uh the Beast out of the
earth will he help none the whole earth
will be without help for you see now
that I even I am here and there is no
God with me I kill I make alive I wound
I heal neither is there any that can
deliver out of my hand for I lift up my
hand to heaven and I say I live forever
if you don't have God you actually have
nothing if I wet my glittering sword and
my hand take hold on judgment I will
render Vengeance to my enemies and I
will reward them that hate me I will
make mine arrows drunk with blood and
then he explains what he's going to do
and then he says Rejoice oh ye nations
with his people for he will avenge the
blood of his servants he will render
Vengeance to his adversaries and will be
merciful upon his land and his people so
God forsook them forever right no no no
no he
didn't every time he still kept the
remnant okay and all the adcs he used to
explain how they were they were they
were all glorious right unfortunately I
I haven't read that yet no and Moses
came and spake all the words of the song
in the ears of the people he and HOSA
the son of nun and Moses made an end of
speaking all these words to all Israel
okay so now you know what Israel was
like we don't have to go into all the
details of what they did we know what
they did yeah and of course we will
never do the same no of course not right
so let's jump from ancient Israel to the
church in
laia and to the angel of the Church of
the Lans right these things says the
amen the faithful the true witness the
beginning of the creation of God do we
have the Sabbath in that verse already
yes yes it's there I Know Thy works that
thou art neither cold nor hot I would
thou were cold or hot so then because
Thou Art lukewarm neither cold nor hot I
will spew thee out of my mouth is that a
warning
definitely because yeah
sorry and that's not a getting out no
it's a it's a spitting
out be careful that you're not spat out
oh yeah for sure why because thou sayest
I am rich and increased with Goods I
have need of nothing and now is not that
thou art wretched and miserable and poor
and blind and naked now when the early
Church The Remnant movement read this
they thought it applied to the other
churches but whoa whoa whoa it actually
applied to them yeah and it's the same
as Israel so we could put that verse in
there and say you got fat and you
started to
kick we could put that in there exactly
the same You Can Read All Those portions
that we just read of the song of Moses I
counsel to buy of me gold tried in the
fire is there a remedy yes there's a
remedy and there was one as well in song
of Moses okay so you have to buy gold
refined in the fire is it going to be
easy to buy get this gold no no no it's
in a furnace it's it's a furnace and
white rment that thou mayest be
clothed that's the righteousness of
Christ right so you have to develop a
character and you have to
appropriate the righteousness of Christ
was there an argument about that in the
church in
1888 yes big big time right almost
almost um lifechanging yes and that the
shame of thy nakedness do not appear and
anoint thine eyes with I solve that thou
mayest see well there's not much of aove
improvement there as many as I love did
he love Israel yes
did he chasen
them did he leave them in the chasing no
I rebuke and chasen be zealous therefore
and repent so does he care
for the last Israel his care has never
changed okay so what's he do I stand at
the door and knock If any man hear my
voice and open the door I will come into
him and will s with him and he with me
to him that overcometh will I grant to
sit with me in my throne
that which Satan coveted and did not
receive he'll give to this people yeah
Martin this is amazing what kind of a
god are we serving here even as I also
overcame and sat down with my father in
his throne it's all encompassing you're
not just sitting on a throne you're part
of the government yeah and he that has
an ear let him hear what the spirit says
to the churches so there are lessons to
be learned so let's make this
straight there are many problems within
the church Y and we have improved upon
the Israelites that's very well put yes
okay so whatever it is that we do we're
worse than them yeah worse than them
worse than them worse
they okay Martin I must leave the church
now because we we've
improved no is there still a knocking
going on exactly all right now we have
to get this picture
right so let's go to early writings
because that's when the hand was
young it started writing and it was only
17 years old and when the people of God
shall attain to primitive faith and
practice as they certainly will by the
proclamation of The Commandments of God
and the fa of Jesus will not the latter
Reign again develop the gifts reasoning
from analogy we should expect it not
withstanding the apostasies of the
Jewish age it opened and closed with
special manifestation of the spirit of
God and it is unreasonable to suppose
that the Christian age the light of
which compared with the former
dispensation is as the light of the Sun
compared with the feeble rays of the
Moon should commence in glory and close
in
obscurity so m in spite of their
apostasies it didn't end in obscurity it
ended with a glorious revelation of the
Messiah and unfortunately only a portion
of Israel accepted and remained in the
Israel of God and the rest was shaken
out out they decided to leave it yes
because they didn't follow the Messiah
if you don't follow the Messiah you're
shaking yourself out you're not shaking
your the others out you're not shaking
the Messiah out
how just think about it Martin how is it
possible for literal Israel to throw the
Messiah out it's it's not possible it's
not possible you can't pick up God and
throw him out you thrown yourself out by
not accepting him that's it the same is
applicable with the final decisions
absolutely so if there's a final
Gathering those who keep the
Commandments of God and hold to the
testimony that's the Gathering are there
any better than Israel no they're worse
exactly but they're still God's people
in spite of not withstanding all right
so it won't go out in obscurity and
since a special work of the spirit was
necessary to prepare a people for the
first Advent of Christ how much more so
for the second especially since the last
days were to be perilous beyond all
precedent and false prophets were to
have power to show great signs and
wonders in so much as it were possible
they should deceive the very elect but
the scriptures of Truth this is where
you have to be grounded ex are we going
to have false prophets in our midst yes
are we going to have bad examples in our
mid oh for sure are we going to have
leadership that's not that's doing worse
than they yes but was there also good
leadership yes weren't there calebs
weren't there joshuas
exactly and he said unto them go ye into
all the world and preach the gospel to
Every Creature he that believeth and is
baptized shall be saved but he that
believeth not shall be damned there will
be a sifting yeah for sure and these
signs shall follow them that believe in
my name they shall cast out Devils they
shall speak with new tongues they shall
take up serpents they shall drink any
deadly thing it shall not hurt them they
shall lay hands on the sick and they
shall recover and did it happen yes all
right do we have those manifestations in
our church no now hardly hardly so what
do we need we need to have a special
outpouring of the Holy Spirit that'll
take place only after the shaking that's
it so Martin we are now the church
militant not the church triumphant come
back to primitive godliness all right so
let's read this last portion the
apostles commission belonged to the
Christian age and embraced the whole of
it consequently the gifts were lost only
through
apostasy and will be revived with the
Revival of primitive faith and
practice so m is God allowing apostasy
within our ranks to wake up some people
yes maybe even to draw the apostates
back yeah he's done it the whole a
Through the Ages okay so why should be
any different now why are the people
standing outside decrying the remnant
for the evils that are within them and
not seeing that there are people
actually in it that are trying to live
up to the light that they have in
Ezekiel 8 where they're crying at the
porch and the altar are they leaving the
church no no they keep on standing and
watching and seeing all the atrocities
and even worse yes the whole time so
what is your job then to weep between
the porch and the altar not to separate
yourself from Park exactly all right
many are trembling with
fear because the work moves faster than
their slow faith and because means is
expanded more rapidly than it comes into
the treasury and yet we have taken only
the first steps in
advance shall we abandon the fields we
have already opened in foreign countries
shall we drop part of the work in our
mission shall We Grow pale at the debt
of a few thousand shall we falter and
become laggards now in the very last
scenes of this Earth history my heart
says no no everything's not going to be
perfect of course not unless we move
forward as the Providence of God opens
the way we won't get anywhere right no
all right so nothing's going to be
perfect we're going to struggle and
there will be accusations flying around
because some of our people you know
might borrow more than others and there
will be criticism do we have Ministries
that are criticized on that level for
sure just to make it plain again that
does not mean that we say you should
stay in a ludian state no nor do we say
go into debt no because there are other
places where she says Shan dead like the
plague MH God's people are to
distinguished as a people who serve him
fully wholeheartedly taking no honor to
themselves and remembering that by a
most solemn Covenant they have bound
themselves to serve the Lord and him
only it is
wholehearted Thoroughly decided men and
women who will stand now Christ sifted
his followers again and again again
until at one time there remained only 11
and a few faithful women to lay the
foundations of the Christian church is
there going to be a sifting was there a
sifting like we've just seen you with
the 12 disciples there are those who
will stand back when burdens are to be
borne but when the church is all a glow
they catch the enthusiasm sing and shout
and become rapturous but watch them when
the fervor is gone only a few faithful
calebs will come to the front and
display unwavering principle we're in a
crucible we have
to wait for the calebs and the joshuas
to manifest themselves no man can
succeed in the service of God unless his
whole heart is in the work and he counts
all things but loss for Excellency of
the knowledge of Christ no man who makes
any reserve can be the disciple of of
Christ much less can he be his co-
laborer all right so in this Crucible
God has a people and he is sifting them
yeah he is shaking them what does it
mean here with makes any no man who
makes any reserve can be a disciple oh
he says I I will certainly help with
this but here uh I will Reserve this
portion for myself I'm not going to go
along with this there must be no
Reserves you need everything everything
I'm that makes me think all right so I
many years ago I gave a sermon called
optional accessories M you know you buy
a machine and then you can buy all
optional
accessories in order to you know do
whatever else you want to do so you buy
the basic
machine but you say I don't need all
this junk so I'm not going to do that
and it works maybe with a machine when
you buy this gospel are there optional
accessories that you can say I don't
need this portion no no this is like
that other machine that you talk about
that's like a irreducible complex
machine yes so everything you cannot
reduce anything you have to take the
whole package so can you say Okay I
accept the Sabbath but I refuse the
health reform no because of the package
you're you're being fanatical yes
exactly
okay so there's been a sifting then you
also have to keep a spirit humble as
that of a little child Envy Pride
worldly ambition cupidity love of ease
must be sacrificed upon the altar of
Duty but these are character changes
that must take place and then she asks
oh for faithful calebs in this age of
the world we want men and women who have
self-control who have moral worth who
love and fear God men who cherish
personal piety firm religious principles
God is Dishonored by a lack of moral
stamina and many who profess to be
Christians they seem to be only half
converted they claim to believe the
truth but they love the luxuries which
are so injurious to health better than
they love the Jesus of the truth they
want an optional accept accessory they
don't want this portion were the Israel
of old in that category oh for sure yeah
they they murmured quite a bit who were
the worst amongst them the mixed
multitude the mixed multitude
fortunately we don't have a mixed
multitude I think we're all about I've
got news for you we are the mixed
multitude and uh you know eating and
drinking are Carri on to excess that
Christ mentioned this condition of
things in the last days Martin likening
it to the condition of the world before
the flood Christ would have his
followers cultivate undeviating
principle it is necessary for the
Christian in thought word and action to
shun everything that leads to
sin Mar do we do
that as a church no some try to do try
you and you see that's the that's a
thing to remember here and in the
testimonies it's talking directly to you
as an individual all right and that is
what it's not your purpose to enforce
all of that on the others all right so
let's just get to the bottom line are we
going to have people that rebel against
Health reforms
yes right there's the highest reason for
us to prize the truth Sabbath and stand
in its defense for it is the sign which
distinguishes the people of God from the
world the Commandment that the world
makes void is the one to which for this
reason God's people will give greater
honor it is when the unbelieving cost
contempt upon the word of God that the
faithful calebs are called for now most
people within this church are there
because they believe the Sabbath right
yeah now I spoke to an editor of one of
our
magazines and I asked him because he was
very liberal why do you keep a
Sabbath and he said because I was born
an Adventist so I said okay if you were
born a Catholic would you keep Sunday he
said yes yeah said doesn't it make any
difference to you he said no so said why
do you keep it then he says because this
is what I was born into this is what I
know is it important to you he say no it
doesn't matter which day
this is an Adventist
speaking now he represents a huge group
because he was the editor of one of our
magazines yeah should I now leave the
church because this individual was
talking such utter nonsense no actually
you should say Lord help him forgive him
because he know not what he do that's
right and the other representative of a
very prominent Nation
uh was holding up his little trinket
there and somebody asked him what is
that he said this is for my
Martini Martin should I leave the church
because he thinks drinking martinis is
fine
no
okay but what did Caleb experience he
saw the stones in the hands of those
that had brought a false report but this
did not deter him he had a message and
he would bear it the same spirit will be
manifested today say to those who are
true to God Martin If You Preach truth
straight truth will there be stones in
other people's hands constantly the
whole time did Caleb leave the church
because of it exactly no he went into
the desert with them for 40 years and
then after into Canaan and he said give
me this mountain with these Giants I'll
take it and that's a very beautiful one
so instead of getting out of the church
and barking say give me these mountains
these apostates I'll go and talk to them
I will go and sort them out and if they
bother you I will take them away with my
sword
so we have these situations the prophet
Malachi says behold I will send
aijah the prophet before the coming of
the great and Dreadful day of the Lord
and he shall turn the hearts of the
fathers to the children and the hearts
of the children to their fathers s is
there a message that is supposed to
touch the heart
yeah the whole message is supposed to
touch your heart all right now if there
is a message is that a guarantee that
all Hearts will be reached no we've got
numerous examples of this the whole time
okay so because it doesn't happen why
you're going to leave the church that's
exactly why you should not leave the
church all right so here the prophet
describes the character of the work
those who are to prepare the way for the
second coming of Christ are represented
by faithful Elijah as John came in the
spirit of Elijah so must the end time
Church come in the spirit of July Elijah
and as John the Baptist ate a pure
plant-based diet and as Daniel as a type
of the end time people said give me
pulse to eat which is a plantbased diet
we should avoid all Health destroying
habits of those who live in this
degenerate age you agree with that oh
for sure you should stand out you should
stand out all right M then why are we
worse than Israel of old because we
adhere to Revelation 14: 6-12 instead of
Revelation all right Martin so here we
have uh let's call it an enacted
Parable or if you want to you can call
it a a political cartoon
yeah and basically you are addressing
God's people and saying we're worse than
they but let let's say we are worse than
they rather than you are worse than they
because we are all louded when Daniel
prayed and asked for forgiveness did he
say they no he said we we have
sinned M
now this little picture over here
actually speaks a thousand words because
here they're sitting at
potluck and they have the roasted
whatevers before them and I don't think
these drinks don't here are necessarily
the best some of them could possibly be
martinis martinis in some cases
definitely in some Churches it could be
coffee which is called a sin in some
places but it can also be power
drinks or
whatever and here on the church it says
sad day church that's a scrambling of
SDA rearranging the words the letters to
read sad day
church now Martin Israel of olded did
they crave the flesh pots of Egypt yes
and they were murmuring and murmuring
and muttering and they said nothing but
this Mana we loathe this food did they
say that yes and did the Lord then give
them what they wanted yes and when they
moaned again did he give it again yes
did they get sick no worse than that all
right and while the flesh was still
between their teeth they received a
wasting disease so Martin they got it on
occasion but our people can get it
whenever they want to every single day
and they make sure they do don't they
yes so are we are we better or worse
than they worse than they worse than
they all right
health foods are to be manufactured in
Kuran bong and are to be sent out to
every place where the standard of Truth
is uplifted the secular papers are
dealing with the question of the cattle
that are brought to the market
disease out of 20 cattle only one or two
are pronounced fit for consumption this
is arousing the reasoning
mind what can be done to take the place
of Flesh meat the people ask this is our
time to work in proper lines to go forth
in the spirit of Elijah and prepare the
way for the Lord are we doing that as a
people are some doing it yes and they
are being
ostracized okay do we have a war
every potlock yeah there's a war right
that's it now Martin God put them on a
healthy diet because he wanted to
restrict them and punish them right yeah
he didn't want the best for them he just
wanted he didn't want the best suffer in
case people don't know we're being
sarcastic no he said I don't want to put
any of the diseases that the egyptions
had upon you and look when you adhere to
my principles because I gave them to you
there was not one feeble one amongst you
in fact your clothes didn't even wear
out let alone your bodies in the last
days isn't it going to be the same the
same and he mentioned it quite a few
times he wanted them clar to have
Clarity of mind yes when I was still at
the University I took my students once a
year I took the students to the
abattoir and Martin for at least a week
after that experience they were all
vegetarians because the carcasses came
down that line and the inspectors would
be standing in a row and the carcass
would come by open and there would be a
huge tumor in the one and they would cut
it out throw it into a bin all of these
diseased portions that would just cut
them out and if the rest looked okay it
got a stamp
Prime and off it went yeah and so they
came down the line with cancer with
tumors with the worst situations and it
really had to be horrendous before it
was class second class or whatever
meat and all of the bad rotten portions
went into a bin what do you think
happened to those it gets processed gets
processed and fed back to the animals
and God said to these end time people
disease is increasing in proportion to
the wickedness of man yeah and the curse
of the earth and I want to protect you
against this and please I want you to
warn the people please be an Elijah for
me please be an example like d Daniel
was and everybody says whatever you have
said Lord we will do that's what Israel
said same didn't they say it when they
were baptized yes they said it right
after they received the Ten Commandments
from Moses as well okay are we going to
leave the church because they the
majority don't want to do it no okay
well just coming back to this worse than
they do you think the situation today is
worse then out of 20 cattle only one or
two are pronounced fit for consumption
Martin do you want me to take you to the
abattoir as well but what about um
cattle that I have in my backyard
beautiful grass-fed ones yes Martin have
you noticed that disease is increasing
in proportion to the wickedness of man
have you noticed that when you were
young you got a cold or you got a flu or
whatever and you still went to work and
carried on now you're flat on your bed
on a respirat probably yeah in most
cases what's happened and why are the
zentic diseases being transferred from
one species to another we're living in a
chaotic world and God meant it for good
and we took it for evil for sure and so
Martin I saw that many who profess to
believe the truth for these last days
think it
strange that the children of Israel
murmured as they
journeyed that after the one wonderful
dealings of God with them they should be
so ungrateful as to forget what he had
done for them said the angel you have
done worse than
they Martin worse than
they I saw that God has given his
servants the truth so clear so plain
that it cannot be resisted wherever they
go they have certain Victory the enemies
cannot get around the convincing truths
what if you don't know the truth Martin
then you have to study it ah now Martin
why are the people leaving the church
because of a lack of knowledge and they
don't know the truth yeah but they're
standing outside the church and barking
exactly and there's a difference because
I've heard this many times you can have
all the head knowledge and maybe they've
got too much knowledge but if you don't
have a heart change and making that
knowledge your own that is what what
means with having a lack of knowledge
our parents instructing their children
is the church instructing their CH the
children or are some Churches let not be
blanket are some Churches more engaged
in
entertaining the people rather than
teaching the people exactly we're tired
of these dry sermons yes we don't want
it to be so boring why is the youth
leaving the church but I've been in
churches where there was an adult sermon
followed by a youth
sermon where in scripture do you read
Jesus saying excuse me youth go sit and
play soccer over there until I finished
with the old folks then I'll give you a
sermon as to how better to score the
goals did he ever do that no why don't
we
Embrace and teach and admonish
even if people rebel against it instruct
them while they are young and when they
are old they will not depart from it
don't water down the message because
they're young yeah so sometimes they
make trials for themselves they imagine
trials and are so easily discouraged and
so easily hurt and self digity is so
quick to feel the peer pressure gets at
them and they leave the church but we're
worse than Israel of
old so God in Mercy called them out from
the Egyptians that they might worship
him without hindrance or restraint he
wrought for them in the way by Miracles
he proved he tried them by bringing them
into straight places after the wonderful
dealings of God with them and their
Deliverance so many times they murmured
when tried or proved by him their
language was would God we had died by
the hand of the Lord in the land of
Egypt they lusted for the leaks and the
onions there said the angel you've done
worse than
they Martin we're worse does it make us
any less God's people
no all right Martin what does this
picture say picture is worth a thousand
words all right so here you have a
pastor he's a liberal Pastor he might
even be a liberal conference
it could possibly be a liberal Division
I don't know Martin he has a book which
says
Revelation 14:
6-12 that's the Three Angels messages
with the b instead of a v right
Revelation and he is about to join
to in gorgeous Apparel in
matrimony but they both have
beards do we have this within our ranks
it's sad to say but yes is it an
official policy that we Embrace this
sort of thing in the church h no is it
done in the church yes it's
unfortunately done all right is it done
in conferences
yes uh must I now leave the church
because they are apostate no on the I
weat between the porch and the altar yes
and you should stand firm and bring the
truth to to the fall
okay do I have to uh address every
single situation or can I say this is
not in harmony with God's
word well from everything we've read up
until now there was not one individual
called out but the apostasy so of course
we should call out the apost right the
apostasy is wrong now you know the Bible
says in the days of Paul in Romans 1:26
for this cause God gave them up unto
vile affections for even though women
did change the natural use unto that
which is against nature was it a problem
in Paul's day did the Israelites indulge
in this sort of activity yes definitely
okay Sodom and
gomor way before Paul's time already all
right so mod is it happening in our
ranks yes does it make it right no not
at all does it make the whole church
Babylon
no
okay so this message has not had the
influence that it should have had upon
the mind and the Heart of the Believers
the true state of the church is to be
presented before men and they are to
receive the word of God not as something
originating with men but as the word of
God do these people change what God has
said yes yes well they reinterpret what
God has said all right so they
reinterpret what God Said to such an
extent that what God said he actually
didn't say EXA exactly in fact he said
the exact opposite opposite yes right so
when he instituted the state of marriage
mhm in Eden in
Eden there was no ambiguity as to what
was happening there right yeah okay so
why should there be ambiguity now
because science has said that your genes
are very fluid with regard to this issue
which is of course nonsense because a
male has a white chromosome and a woman
does not yeah but let's leave it at that
so many have treated the message to the
louded Sans as it has come to them as
the word of
man both message and messenger have been
held in doubt by those who would have
been the first to discern and act upon
it as the word of God had they received
the word of God sent to them they would
not now be in darkness for I would that
ye knew what great conflict I have for
you and for them at louded Sea and for
as many as have not seen my face in the
flesh that their hearts may be comforted
being knit together in love and unto all
Riches of the full Assurance of
understanding to the acknowledgement of
the mystery of God and the father of
Christ this is the letter to the coloss
and Paul is referring to the
Lans and he's saying read this epistle
to them as well yeah and he's
pained but it's still God's church it's
good still God's church so Martin we
actually have a message of warning and
mercy it's a message of warning and
mercy to the
outside but it also Cuts both ways it's
a double-edged sword it's so important
but you must remember we've always said
Jesus walks in the middle of those two
words so much excellent labor was
bestowed upon the Lan Church to them was
given the exaltation be ye therefore
perfect even as your father which is in
heaven is perfect but the church did not
follow up the work begun by God's
Messengers they heard but they failed to
appropriate the truth to themselves and
to carry out the instruction given them
the result that follow followed is the
result always sure to follow the
rejection of the Lord's warnings and
entreaties just because there are people
that go against God's wisdom and
admonishment doesn't make the whole body
apostate
yeah in every age the Lord has sent
messages to point out the right way and
just as surely as men have United in
Walking contrary to the plain word of
God so surely have they been used by
Satan to carry out his Pur purposes some
to whom the Lord has for years been
sending messages have clearly understood
and have magnified every word of
encouragement but have treated it as if
they were of not the cautions the
warnings and the
reproofs still happening it's happening
today so self-satisfaction is to be
dreaded this is why the Jewish Nation
did not receive Christ and we are worse
yeah so let's read the highlighted
portion many are assimilating with the
world and leaving upon human Minds the
impression that the special messages of
warning giving in the 14th of Revelation
messages that have called us out from
the world are secondary to the medical
missionary work no we are like the Jews
of old right exactly the same repeating
the same mistakes all right so if we go
to our churches some of them Revelation
14:
6-12 do we have these manifestations
within our church yes and most of the
time it is on the premises that we
should keep or bring in the youth do we
have people in our churches that invite
people from outside that speak in
tongues
and do all these type of singing that I
think is hurting God's ears bedum of
noise yes do we have in very high
positions within the church uh leaders
that are in contact with very prominent
people in the world that speak in
tongues yes oh but is it right no not at
all okay so do we have these
manifestations within the within the
church and it's getting worse obviously
all right and let's say particularly if
you are associated with the youth there
would be places like youth churches or
universities uh is there a tendency to
move in this direction yes it's not even
a tendency anymore it's not a tendency
does it make it right no no do I have to
put onto the screen every single
individual that is doing this or is the
principle enough the principle should be
enough because when you then walk into
any place where you see this you know
that it has to be addressed and we don't
have to say good riddens we've got rid
of one of these that we've shown but
there's still so many others I remember
this one youth church where I was
speaking there were drums on the
stage in one place there were numerous
sets of drums they were trying to outdo
the heaviest Med bands that that existed
and uh I've told these stories before
and I found this young man standing
outside and I said why are you not there
with your friends in there he says my I
can't go in there I said why are you
standing here then he says because my
friends are in there I said why are you
not in there he says because my Jesus is
not in there that was such an amazing
thing and then later on spoke to more
and more young people and they all
agreed that they didn't really want to
be in there it was peer pressure they
were carrying on like a
maniacal situation I had another
situation where there were drums on the
stage and a bedum of noise and the
pastor came with his shirt unbuttoned
down to here with an electric guitar and
a massive earring in one ear and it was
an SDA
pastor and then it was my turn to give a
talk I never mentioned a word of
anything that was was going on on the
stage and when IID finished my talk one
of the young people in the audience
piped up and said excuse me will you
please tell us what you think about all
the drums on the stage and all of this
sort of
thing and I said I'm delighted to see
them and there was deathly silence and I
carried on talking and whatever I did
and then after about a minute or two I
said by the way do you want to know why
I'm delighted to see them and they said
yes why so I said because the spirit of
Prophecy says just before the close of
probation drums will come into the
Adventist Church and I'm delighted to
see them because I really want to go
home amen so Martin was that a rebuke
yes in a parable exactly all right so
did you leave the church no exactly did
they leave the church maybe maybe not
maybe some of them changed maybe not I
don't
know so Satan's object is accomplished
just as surely when men run ahead of
Christ and do the work he has never
entrusted to their hand as when they
remain in the Lan State lukewarm feeling
rich and increased with goods and in
need of nothing the two classes are
equally stumbling blocks oh that's a
very odd one there some people run ahead
mhm and some people will run so far
ahead that they condemn the entire
churches Babylon yeah because they see
these things within the church I tell
you brother my brother and sister we are
living in the loudan state of the church
if any ever needed to fall upon the rock
and be broken it is the people of
California and all through our church in
America we need to arouse and act as one
man we need to be Earnest and Alive
Horrors upon Horrors are following upon
the destruction of human life yet these
things receive only few remarks the
world will not be warned by the day the
Lord is coming unawares as a thief in
the night you know if we keep on parting
and thinking we must become like the
world we're going it's a serious problem
you're going to be part of the whole
shaking out per process M this is a
rather horrendous
little what shall we call this
rendition here you have obviously one
who knows about The Three Angels message
but he's in Rebellion it says Revelation
6-12 it should actually say
Revelation so what is this person doing
he's kneeling in front an of an
altar within a church
system that does not portray
righteousness by faith no right and
maybe this pastor or individual or
church or conference or Union or
whatever you would like to call them are
in ecumenical
councils maybe this guy is sitting maybe
maybe they even in The ecumenical
council maybe they're even chairing some
of the
meetings is this the official position
of the church no no uh do some people
individuals maybe churches maybe
conferences maybe higher than that say
we don't care what the official position
is we're going to do it anyway yes do
they then turn their weapons against
those that aren't teaching Revelation 14
but Revelation 14 exactly they are the
enemy they become the enemy is that a
reason to leave the church no because
did Moses leave the church because of
Kora no he didn't leave but do we have
coros in the Church of course but do we
have calebs
yes ah Martin now this is a very serious
issue so we do have these things in the
church are they to be commended or to be
condemned
condemned and if you do condemn it will
you have enemies within the church yes
and just to make certain you do not
condemn the person no because you don't
know yeah because you cannot sit on the
the Judgment chair you cannot say this
person is
lost because you don't know what's going
to happen to him but the sin for sure I
always remember that Pastor who
absolutely abhor my
messages he was so rebellious and
interesting he also had a guitar around
his neck now please don't misunderstand
me my wife has a guitar around her neck
most days
I do not condemn a guitar it depends
what you do with that guitar my son has
a guitar around his neck most days but
he also had a guitar in his past life
and played heavy metal in a band on
it so it's what you do with the guitar
but anyway this pastor he was very
antagonistic about
everything until right at the end he
came to me and apologized
and I said what happened did you listen
to what I said no he hadn't listened to
a word but his
grandmother had said to him now I can
die in peace because I know that the
Adventist message is still alive and
That Shook him to the core so Martin I
don't know what's going to happen to a
person I don't know how God is going to
speak to him I don't know whether that
Aaron is going to become a faithful yeah
minister in the end and what a heavy
price poor Aaron paid isn't that yeah
yeah he lost his children so yes do we
have this in the church unfortunately
yes does it make it Babylon no
no we will be called to stand before
rulers and Kings human enactments Lords
manufactured by satanic agencies under a
plea of goodness and restriction of evil
will be exalted
while God's holy Commandments are
despised and Trampled Under Foot and all
who prove their loyalty by obedience to
the law of Jehovah must be prepared to
be arrested to be brought before
councils that that have not for their
standarded the high and holy law of God
are you prepared to be arrested for this
for God yes but I must be careful lest I
think I stand and I fall correct because
Peter said the same
okay many will have to stand in
legislative courts some will have to
stand before Kings and before the loned
of the earth to answer for their faith
those who have only a superficial
understanding of truth will not be able
to clearly expound the scriptures and
give definite reasons for their faith
they will become confused and will not
be workmen that need to not be ashamed
let no one imagine that he has no need
to study because he is not to preach in
the sacred desk you know not what God
may require of you Martin how important
is it that our children are
educated how important is it that those
who claim to be Adventists know why they
are Seventh Day Advent that is probably
the most important thing for for any
Adventist you must know why you are one
and if the whole world is raid against
you if you do not have a thus says the
Lord and who's going to be our biggest
enemies our own
ranks
okay but this is what's happening in the
world we all know it that it's happening
or we should know that it's happening
and those in high places should take
cognizance of what's happening and if
they're sitting in ecumenical councils
and think that those Brethren are more
in line with God's world than the others
let them think again the Ten
Commandments must be on display in every
classroom and other laws it's hard to
believe are real from Banning buses to
MKS to talking about slavery here are
some of the wackiest and most terrifying
state laws being pushed in recent years
it's going to be a whole package deal
let's bring the Commandments back so
this week Louisiana
Republican Governor Jeff Landry signed a
law mandating that the Ten Commandments
yes Thou shalt not commit adultery Etc
be displayed in every public school he
has been pushing a hard right Christian
agenda since coming into office 6 months
ago and then he said if you want to
respect the rule of law you've got to
start from the original lawgiver which
was Moses actually it was God yes
actually Moses was just a messenger yes
I must say actually on that video the
lady sitting next to him helped him
right and he then acknowledged yes okay
God okay so this becomes a Christian
nationalist movement right and not only
the Ten Commandments they have other
laws that they are
introducing and it's part of the the
push in the Republican party and some of
them are going ahead like the governor
of Florida and all of these Oklahoma and
many others as well and now they've
brought in laws that you may not only
address the pronouns that are on your
birth
certificate all right so is there a push
against the liberalism yes for sure
there's a big because the King of the
South pushed against the King of the
North now there are some moral laws that
you might agree with here for sure will
Sunday be part of the package yes yes
the appeal to Heaven flag used during
January 6 Capital riots and seen flying
out outside the home of the Supreme
Court justice has been linked to
Christian nationalism so the government
the legal system they're moving in that
direction Martin we are so close and
we're going to be brought
before councils and they're going to
deride us and they're going to mock us
it does not seem possible to us now that
any should have to stand
alone but if God has ever spoken by me
the time will come when we shall be
brought before councils before thousands
for his name's sake and each one will
have to give give a reason of his
faith mustn't we study exactly because
if you're going to be asked why do you
believe the 72 weeks prophecy and you
say but I don't know what the 72 week
prophecy is you going to have a trouble
yes and you people got it all wrong in
1844 didn't
you then will come the severest
criticism upon every position that has
been taken for the truth we need then to
study the word of God that we may know
why we believe the doctrines we Advocate
how important is it it's like well it's
going to you're going to have it to make
a decision yes at that's importance and
we're just a small group that is trying
to preach some of these things what
impact can we have it's not my worries
that's God's worries
right God means that testing truth shall
shall be brought to the front and become
a subject of examination and discussion
even if it is through the contempt
placed upon it the minds of the people
must be agitated every controversy every
reproach every slander will be God's
means of provoking inquiry and Awakening
Minds that otherwise would Slumber are
we for heading for a conflict we are and
that just gives you a little bit of
encouragement when these people stand
start accusing you and everything that's
opportunity correct for
God now Martin some of us must be
willing to go to prison right so we must
go to prison trusting him as child
trusts his parents the popular Ministry
like the Pharisees of old filled with
anger as their Authority is questions
will denounce the message as of Satan
and stir up the sin loving multitudes to
revile and persecute those who Proclaim
it now when you say that that which is
from God is from Satan you're committing
the sin against the Holy Spirit yeah we
are in the shaking time the time when
everything that can be shaken will be
shaken the Lord will not excuse those
who know the truth if they do not in
word and deed obey his
commands Martin there are no optional
accessories in this
church if we make no effort to win souls
to Christ we shall be held responsible
for the work we might have done but did
not do because of our spiritual
indolence and if we don't work for Souls
out there but spend our time shouting at
those
within Martin are we missing the boat
you've said before that's
when the Watchmen on the wall have
turned their
backs to the and are facing inward are
facing inward yes and they should be
facing outward and watching what's
happening exactly but they've
become policemen Watchmen of their
brothers yeah or barkers of the brothers
they're not even standing on the wall
they're standing
outside those who belong to the Lord's
Kingdom must work earnestly for the
saving of souls they must do their part
to bind up the law and seal it amongst
their disciples this is our work
mhm now
Martin the fact that there is apostasy
amongst our
ranks let's make it quite clear it
doesn't make us Babylon no no so as the
storm approaches a large class that's a
terrible word there who have professed
faith in the third Angel's message but
have not been Sanctified through
obedience to the truth in other words
they're reading Revelation rather than
the
Revelation they abandon their position
and join the ranks of the
opposition so by joining the world and
partaking of its spirit that become so
that they see it in the same light as
the others those people are Fanatics and
everything goes let's bring in the the
drums and let's bring in the take away
everything that's holy correct so they
will choose the easy popular side men of
talent pleasing address that once
rejoiced in the truth will employ their
powers to deceive and mislead Souls they
become the most bitter enemies of their
former Brethren when Sabbath keepers are
brought before the courts to answer for
their faith these apostates are the most
efficient agents of Satan to
misrepresent and accuse them and by
false reports and insinuations to stir
up the rulers against them you know
people are constantly sending us
videos of EX believers who have nothing
better to do than argue about this
Doctrine or that Doctrine or whatever
whatever the doctrine is whether it be
Health reform yeah or whether it be the
investigative
judgment why is it that they do not
study from cause to effect they haven't
got the fuest clue as to what the
pre-advent judgment is all about but
they condemn everybody that believes it
therefore they condemn everybody that
believes what God word has to say ex and
these join people like for instance Kim
Iverson and redacted that made videos
now because because of the health
message this church has this church has
been ostracized by the people that
everybody is so fond
of because they're conservative correct
and showing out the other things this
will be the some of the misleading and
it'll be a test for the people of God so
in concluding this narrative I would say
that we are living in the most solemn
time in the last Vision given me I was
shown the startling fact that but a
small portion of those who profess the
truth will be Sanctified by it and saved
Martin the majority is going to be
lost
so this whole episode that we are
conducting
here is it an accusation or is it an
appeal it's an
appeal please start studying know why
you are in this church know why you
believe the doctrines know why no matter
what the world throws at you God's word
is your Bas yeah and if there is things
that are in your life that you have to
sort out sort them out sort them out
don't point fingers to everybody else
and if you see the Splinter or even the
beam in your brother's eye you can warn
against what they're doing but you do
God's work that's it
so many will get above the Simplicity of
the work they will conform to the world
cherish Idols become spiritually Dead
The Humble self-sacrificing followers of
Jesus will pass on to Perfection leaving
behind the indifferent and lovers of the
world don't just look at the negative in
the
church do what is right leave the
consequences to God yeah the shaking of
God blows away multitudes like dry
leaves
so if they are blown away are they then
shaken out or who's leaving they are
blown away they are going
out they will be shaken out those that
believe will remain so those that have
left already because they think that the
church has now become so bad because
some Pastor bows down to an idle altar
or bows down to whatever has made the
whole Church Babylon they've missed the
point yes we are worse than they but
they we are still the apple of God's eye
let's have a look at
it when the law of God is made void the
church will be sifted by fiery trials
and a larger proportion than we now
anticipate will give heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of devils we have
to weep weep between the porch and the
altar we have to plead with our
Brethren but we have to preach a
straight testimony to the world
yes instead of being strengthened when
brought into straight places many prove
that they are not living branches of the
True Vine they bear no fruit and the
husbandman takes them away but who's the
husbandman it's Jesus it's not you and I
no I'm not the
one so what's going to happen Martin
standard of the standard was left to
Trail in the dust company after company
from the Lord's army joined the Foe and
the tribe after tribe from the ranks of
the enemy United with the Commandment
keeping people of God there's going to
be a
switch I want to say to those that are
barking on the
outside come back in and bark to the
outside leave it to the husbandman as to
who will remain and who won't but bark
at the apostasy but not the individual
all right when the shaking has taken
place what's going to be left the
numbers of the company had lessened some
had been shaken out and left by the way
the careless indifferent who did not
join with those who prized Victory and
salvation enough to agonize persevere
and ple for it did not obtain it and
they were left behind in darkness and
their numbers were immediately made up
by others taking hold of the truth and
coming into the ranks this is exactly
what happened to Israel of old yes they
didn't consider it Worthy or great
enough to follow the Messiah so they
were left behind yes and others Gentiles
joined the ranks and came in and made up
the numbers so the church Remnant
carried on so what happened to Israel
evolved will happen at the end the exact
same thing and the fact that we are
improving on their
apostasy is just part of the signs of
the times and a ful M of Prophecy yes so
not withstanding the agencies combined
against the truth a large number take
their stand upon the Lord's Side the
Lord's cause will
Triumph so the church may appear as
about to fall but it does not fall it
remains while the sinners in Zion be
sifted out M does this not reach the
people out
there that are constant ly decrying this
Church's Babylon and come back and
refuse to come back the chaff separated
from the precious wheat this is a
terrible ordeal but nevertheless it must
take place the bull workk of Satan will
never Triumph Victory will attend the
third Angel's message as the captain of
the Lord's host tore down the walls of
Jericho so will the Lord's commandment
keeping people Triumph and all opposing
elements will be
defeated that's the bottom
line probation is almost ended Get Ready
Get Ready while the day lasts for the
night cometh when no man can work Martin
I think we should conclude on that one
so what we have
said is in spite of the condition of the
church militant it is the apple of the
Lord's eye the shaking is God's work
not my work I have not been appointed as
the
Shaker and neither have you no and we
condemn the apostasy just as much as
anyone out there wants correct but we
can do it in a Christian way and we can
do it according to the Lord's
methodology and if you find your brother
is in sin then go to him and speak to
him and if he is influencing and bring
bringing people into straight places
then take it to the church and let them
deal with it as best they can and if the
whole church is apostate then go to
another one that is not apostate as as
easy as that but the
body you leave that shaking to the Lord
amen let's
pray Heavenly
Father it is a sad State of
Affairs that we are more efficient at
apostasy than Israel of
old but Lord our extremities are God's
opportunities and the shaking that is
taking place that is taking place now
already will sift the wheat and the cha
and separate the two from each other it
is a terrible ordeal and fortunately it
is not in our hands it is in your hands
and I pray that what is left will
fulfill the prophecy and bring the loud
cry and multitudes in the valley of
decision will take their stand on the
Lord's Side let this be the outcome of
this experiment with sin that we have
experienced now for 6,000 years is my
prayer in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]